sehr geehrte Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir gehen jetzt in den
dritten Herbst der Pandemie und wir
wissen wirklich nicht wie die Pandemie
sich im Herbst entwickeln wird der
Expertenrat der Bundesregierung hat mit
drei Szenarien gearbeitet einem leichten
Szenario einem mittelschweren Szenario
und einem schweren Szenario das
mittelschwere Szenario ist im Moment am
wahrscheinlichsten und sehr froh dass
wir mit einer Variante wieder derzeit
dominierenden ba5 Variante zu tun hätten
oder einer vergleichbaren Variante wie
ba275 egal was kommen wird egal was das
Szenario zum Schluss sein wird wir
werden diesmal sehr gut vorbereitet sein
und ich kann jetzt schon sagen wir
werden im Herbst die Lage gemeinsam im
Griff haben mit der Vorbereitung die wir
hier haben
ich will das mir das hier auch
ausleuchten wir haben im Prinzip mit
vier also grundsätzlichen
Initiativen die Vorbereitung gestartet
zum einen wir sind mit Impfstoffen jetzt
ausgestattet die sehr wirksam sind zum
zweiten wir haben eine viel bessere
Arzneimitteltherapie organisiert zum
dritten wir haben eine viel bessere
Datenlage als wir sie jemals gehabt
haben und zum vierten wir haben einen
Infektionsschutzgesetz vorbereitet womit
wir auf jedes der drei Szenarien sofort
reagieren könnten ich fange
fangen wir mit der Impfkampagne mit den
Impfstoffen an wir haben Impfstoffe die
für die Varianten die wir derzeit kennen
und sehen eine sehr gute Wirkung haben
und somit nicht nur besser schützen vor
schwerem Verlauf sondern von den Studien
die wir derzeit haben auch abgeleitet
besser schützen vor der Infektion das
heißt wir können über die Impfungen auch
die Zahl der Infektionen wieder
zurückdrängen das sind Impfstoffe die
besonders gut wirken für diejenigen die
besonders gefährdet sind und wir werden
in den nächsten Wochen eine Kampagne
machen dass jeder genau versteht wie
diese Impfstoffe wirken für wen sie
besonders geeignet sind und wir werden
die Impfstoffe auch so verteilen dass
sie leicht zugänglich sind über die
Impfzentren über die Praxen über die
Apotheken leichter Zugang von
Impfstoffen die gut wirkend über die wir
gut aufgeklärt haben im Rahmen einer
deutschlandweiten Kampagne
ich möchte hier noch einmal ganz
ausdrücklich sagen es wird immer wieder
also bemängelt wenn ich über Medikamente
spreche das wäre nicht angemessen wir
würden Reklame für Medikamente machen
wir können dankbar sein wir können
dankbar sein dass wir jetzt erstmalig
Medikamente haben die bei den
älteren Menschen und bei den Männern
Menschen die Risikofaktoren haben die
Sterblichkeit um 80 bis 90 Prozent
reduzieren wir können alle dankbar sein
dass wir diese Medikamente haben wir
können dankbar sein und dieser
Pauschale billige Vorwurf gegen die
pharmazeutische Industrie ist nicht
platziert dem pharmazeutische Industrie
hat diese Medikamente entwickelt wir
werden sie anwenden wir nutzen sie
derzeit zu wenig aber damit können wir
die Zahl der Todesfälle reduzieren wir
dürfen uns nicht daran gewöhnen dass wir
jetzt jeden Tag 100 Menschen sterben
dürfen das nicht so Normalität werden
lassen wir müssen mit Impfungen
[Applaus]
auch aus der AFD möchten Sie die
zulassen
ich komme
ich komme zu dem dritten Punkt der
pandemie-radler wir haben diesmal auch
deutlich bessere Daten wir haben bis zu
2000 Krankenhäuser haben wir über das
demnis-system an das
Robert-Koch-Institut angeschlossen so
dass jetzt tagesaktuell die Fallzahlen
haben die behandelt werden wir haben die
tatsächlich belegbaren Betten wir haben
zu jedem Zeitpunkt auch die Entwicklung
der Pandemie wir haben einen
abwassermonitoring zum ersten Mal wir
haben die Fallzahlen aus den
intensivregistern und wir werden auch
erstmalig besser unterscheiden können
wer kommt wegen koved ins Krankenhaus
wer kommt mit Kurve ins Krankenhaus und
die Krankheit wird aber mit kovit
verschlimmert oder man stirbt sogar an
einer anderen Krankheit aber die wäre
ohne die Kurve Infektion nicht so
tödlich verlaufen oder ist es eine Kurve
Infektion die sich auf den
Krankheitsverlauf nicht auswirkt somit
können wir deutlich bessere Daten
tagesaktuell anbieten daran haben wir
monatelang gearbeitet das ist viel zu
spät gekommen das ist genau das was uns
im letzten Herbst gefehlt hat und jetzt
haben wir es vorbereitet über den Sommer
wir werden es nutzen
und schließlich der vierte Punkt ich
komme zum Infektionsschutzgesetz das
Infektionsschutzgesetz erlaubt es uns
auf jedes der drei Szenarien sofort
einzugehen wir haben Basismaßnahmen aber
wir können zusätzliche Maßnahmen
einbringen über die Länder wenn dies
notwendig ist wir Schürzen im
Fernverkehr in der Bahn im Fernverkehr
in Bussen wir schützen dort mit der
ffp2-maske diejenigen die dort lange
Strecken fahren wir schützen in den
Krankenhäusern in den Kliniken in den
Praxen in den Pflegeeinrichtungen über
den verschärften Schutz mit der
ffp2-maske deutlich besser als in der
Vergangenheit und werden somit in diesen
Bereichen wo wir sonst viele gefährliche
Infektionen erwarten müssen werden wir
die Zahl der Infektionen deutlich senken
ich möchte das hier klar sagen ich höre
das oft jetzt haben wir hier leichtere
merken und trotzdem wird die
maskenpflicht hier verschärft wir gehen
jetzt über vom der op-maske zur
ffp2-maske macht das Sinn einer
harmlosere Variante und trotzdem die
wirksamere Maske ja und zwar deshalb
weil die weniger gefährliche Variante
deutlich ansteckender ist daher ist es
wissenschaftlich sicher wir müssen die
Masken so bewerten wenn wir Masken
tragen müssen sie auch wirken und bei
diesen Varianten wie BA 275 oder ba5
wirken nur die ffp2-masken sicher daher
bedanke ich mich dass Kollege Buschmann
aber auch die Fraktionen hier
mitgegangen sind und haben dem
wissenschaftlichen Sachstand Platz
gemacht ich weiß dass das schwer zu
erklären ist aber und es gibt auch Leute
denen wir das niemals erklären können
aber darauf verzichten wir wir halten
zusammen wir gehen mit der Wissenschaft
das waren auch die Experten der wir
gehen Expertenrat und die nicht die
niederträchtige die niederträchtigen
Bemerkungen von der Seite werden nicht
dazu beitragen dass wir das nicht
umsetzen weil mittlerweile auch in der
Medizin das Konsens ist die Wissenschaft
geht voran wir steigen da nicht mehr aus
ich komme zu den weiteren Maßnahmen die
wir ergriffen haben wir erlauben es den
Ländern wir ermöglichen es den Ländern
die maskenpflicht in den Innenräumen
wieder einzuführen sollte dies Medizin
nicht geboten sind wer ermöglichen es
den Ländern mit Testungen die
maskenpflicht zu ergänzen wir
ermöglichen es den Ländern mit frischen
genesenen nachweisen und frischen
impfnachweisen die das einlassmanagement
in den Innenräumen in der Gastronomie
bei den Veranstaltungen zu verbessern
wir ermöglichen den sie dem wir die
corona-warn-app vereinfachen und den
dort ein fischertest ein frische impf
oder einer frischer genesenen Status mit
einer grünen Farbe sofort erkennbar ist
somit wir ermöglichen es den Ländern
zielgenau je nach pandemischer Lage
genau das anzubieten was notwendig ist
nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger aber
die Länder sind dann zu jedem Zeitpunkt
vorbereitet und können auf diese
Maßnahmen und werden auf diesen
Maßnahmen auch zurückgreifen es gibt
jetzt noch den Wunsch nach einer
Zwischenfrage aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
bitteschön
ja vielen Dank Herr Bundesminister dr
Lauterbach dass sie die Zwischenfrage
zulassen möchte auf zwei Aspekte
eingehen zum einen sie haben gerade
davon gesprochen dass die Länder die
Möglichkeit erhalten sollen zielgenau in
den Innenräumen eine maskenpflicht
anordnen zu können und ein Verzicht auf
eine mögliche maskenpflicht dann bei
entsprechenden Testungen oder eine
Impfung nach drei Monaten möglich wäre
sie sprechen von zielgenau der Punkt ist
aber im Gesetzentwurf stehende
unbestimmte Rechtsbegriffe die Länder
wissen nicht ab welchen Schwellen sie
überhaupt eine maskenpflicht anordnen
können wenn wir das den Begriff der
Verhältnismäßigkeit weil es auch ein
Grundrechte und Grundrechtseingriffe
geht ernst nehmen bei meine ich schon
hätten sie in diesem Gesetzentwurf ganz
konkrete Schwellenwerte festlegen müssen
ab denen die Länder befugt sind
entsprechende maskenpflichten anzuordnen
zweiter Punkt nochmal zurückkommen zur
maskenpflicht in den Verkehrsmitteln mit
diesem Gesetzentwurf wird ja in den
Flugzeugen die maskenpflicht abgeschafft
während in den Fernzügen die
maskenpflicht durch ffp2-maske
verschärft wird könnten sie doch mal
erklären was denn vor dem Hintergrund
der Verhältnismäßigkeit der Unterschied
zwischen einem Flugzeug und einem
ice-wagon ist ich will jetzt nicht die
HEPA-Filter hören weil typischerweise in
Flugzeugen sind übrigens die Menschen
enger zusammen übrigens auch zwei oder
drei Stunden und in den Fernzügen nicht
vielleicht könnten sie das noch mal
evidenzbasiert darlegen auch mit Verweis
auf die Regelungen in anderen
europäischen Staaten
die erste Frage ist eine sehr wichtige
Frage wieso haben wir keine fixen
Grenzwerte genommen zum Beispiel an
inzidenzwert oder beispielsweise so und
so viele Betten sind belegt naja beim
inzidenzwert können wir zum Beispiel
davon abhängen was es für eine Variante
wie gefährlich ist die Variante oder
werden sie jetzt bei den Betten also
sprechen als die Frage wie lange liegen
die Leute was sind das für Betten somit
ist die beste Umsetzung und das haben
wir uns auch die also Rechtsgelehrten
aber auch also die erfahrenen Experten
gesagt und da bin ich auch der Expertise
von Kollegen Marco Buschmann gefolgt die
beste
Arbeitsweise ist hier dass man die
sogenannte Gesamtschau heranzieht aber
bei der Gesamtschau müssen Daten
berücksichtigt werden somit die schnelle
Antwort ist Daten ja und damit haben wir
mit dem pandemierradar viel vorbereitet
also ja Daten aber keine fixen
Grenzwerte das ist der rechtliche stand
damit arbeiten wir und das ergab auch
übrigens die Auswertung der
Gerichtsurteile in der Vergangenheit wir
wollten Gerichtsurteile in der
Vergangenheit in der haben in der Regel
die getroffenen Maßnahmen dann bestätigt
wenn eine Gesamtschau mit Daten gegeben
wurde wenn man aber nicht versucht hat
mit einem fixen Grenzwert das zu
arrondieren somit ist die Lage und da
bin ich wirklich Marco Buschmann auch
dankbar wir haben darüber sehr viel
gesprochen und wir haben auch also uns
mit Rechtsexperten sehr intensiv
ausgetauscht es klingt zunächst einmal
weniger plausibel aber es ist so viele
Daten ich sage mal in der Vergangenheit
in der Vergangenheit hatten wir wenig
Daten aber fixer Werte diesmal haben wir
viele Daten aber arbeiten ohne fixe
Werte das wird besser sein der zweite
Punkt der zweite Punkt ist
wo lebt der Unterschied zwischen einem
also Zug und einem zunächst einmal es
sind in Deutschland es geht ja um die
gesamtgefahrenabwehr es sind in
Deutschland natürlich sehr viel mehr
Züge unterwegs und sehr viel mehr
Menschen in Zügen unterwegs als pflegen
und zum zweiten es ist einfach so obwohl
die Luft durch wälzung im Flugzeug nicht
perfekt ist ist jedoch deutlich
intensiver auch ausweichlich der Studien
als in einem Bus oder in einem Zug somit
ist dass ein großer Unterschied daher
sind die Züge deutlich gefährlicher und
betreffen auch eine viel größere Gruppe
von Menschen dennoch ist es so wenn die
pandemische Lage es notwendig macht dann
können wir und werden wir als Regierung
auch in den Flugzeugen die ffp2-maske
wieder einführen also wenn es
tatsächlich pandemisch notwendig ist
dann haben wir dafür die
Verordnungsermächtigung werden das auch
tun ab und werden dann auch nicht zögern
das zu tun aber jetzt kann man das gut
vertreten zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt kann
man von der ffp2-maske in den Flugzeugen
noch Abstand nehmen insbesondere dass
sie sehr schwer durchzusetzen ist die
Flugbegleiter können das zum Teil nicht
durchsetzen und wussten ganzer Flüge
abgesagt werden weil es nicht
durchsetzbar war
ich komme
zum komme zum Schluss wir werden wir
werden in diesem Herbst sehr gut
vorbereitet sein und wir sind auch gut
vorbereitet wenn das passiert was ich
nicht hoffe und was ich auch nicht
voraussetze aber wenn es wirklich so
wäre und wir hätten tatsächlich eine
Entwicklung dass wir hohe Fallzahlen
haben viele Patienten mit großem
Schweregrad mehr Sterblichkeit und auch
viele lonkovitfinder dann haben wir das
Instrumentarium um zu reagieren dann
können die maskenpflicht ausgedehnt
werden in den Innenräumen mit der
Testung ohne dass eine Impfung oder ein
genesenstatus eine alternativ ist dann
können wir sogar die maskenpflicht in
den Außenräumen zum Beispiel bei großen
Veranstaltungen können wir diese
einführen und dann können wir auch
Begrenzungen der Personen vornehmen die
an Veranstaltungen oder in Räume
hineinkommen
dann haben wir wirklich ein volles
Instrumentarium somit ich fasse zusammen
wir sind für alle drei Szenarien sehr
gut vorbereitet wir werden die Lage im
Griff haben wir werden versuchen mit so
wenig Einschränkungen der Freiheit der
Menschen wie möglich aber mit so viel
wie nötig zu verhindern dass wir viele
Tote haben dass wir viele schwere Fälle
haben dass wir lohnkovitan das schulden
wir der Bevölkerung wir haben die Lage
im Griff aber wir werden nicht zögern
die Instrumente die wir haben auch
einzusetzen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach zum Gesetzentwurf der
Koalition zu Änderungen am
Infektionsschutzgesetz er sieht
Deutschland gut vorbereitet für den
Herbst und was Corona angeht bessere
Datenlage trage dazu bei und besser
schützende Impfstoffe die auch wieder
mehr vor Infektionen schützen und nicht
nur vor schweren Verläufen es gibt eine
kurze Intervention aus der afd-fraktion
ja
eigentlich gar keine Intervention
stellen aber die Viren und willkürlichen
Regelungen hier lassen wir eigentlich
keine andere Wahl weil mich endlich wie
den Kollegen aus der Union umtreibt dass
uns viele Bürger kontaktiert haben die
gesagt haben wir verstehen gar nicht
diese Regelung mit warum die
maskenpflicht im Flugzeug jetzt fallen
soll hängt es damit zusammen dass man
jetzt den Bundeskanzler und den
Wirtschaftsminister erwischt hat dass
sie ohne Maske geflogen sind und dass
viele Bürger sagen na wenn die ständig
ohne Maske fliegen warum dann nicht wir
die Bürger verstehen auch nicht warum
hier im Parlament nahezu 80 Prozent der
Abgeordneten aller Fraktionen ohne Maske
rumsitzen und sie plötzlich dann wieder
im Zug ffp2-maske tragen müssen das ist
für die Menschen unverständlich wenn
hier 700 Abgeordnete ohne Maske umsetzen
können warum müssen Sie es dann im Zug
halten deswegen wüsste ich gerne von
Ihnen sie haben in der Ausschusssitzung
am Dienstag gesagt es geht um
europaweite Harmonisierung deswegen wird
man im Flugzeug abgeschafft warum machen
Sie nicht auch eine europaweite
Harmonisierung im Bahnverkehr Österreich
freue mich wenn sie von Österreich
kommen wenn sie von Frankreich kommen in
diesen Ländern gibt es keine
maskenpflicht wenn die Leute dann
plötzlich nach Deutschland müssen müssen
Sie die Maske aufsetzen warum machen Sie
eine europaweite Harmonisierung im
Flugverkehr aber keine europaweite
Harmonisierung gleichzeitig im
Bahnverkehr das wäre doch nur konsequent
können Sie das mal eben bitte erklären
die Gelegenheit zu antworten wenn sie es
wollen gut
eine Harmonisierung ist in der Tat immer
sinnvoll aber nicht wenn es eine
Harmonisierung ist so wie sie sich diese
Harmonisierung vorstellen nämlich stetig
nach unten mit immer weniger Sicherheit
dass mehr Menschen sterben dafür stehen
wir nicht zur Verfügung wir wollen
tatsächlich eine Harmonisierung werden
diese ammonisierung dazu dass die
Menschen sicher sind und nicht wenn die
Menschen sterben müssen weil wir keine
Regeln gemacht haben
Karl Lauterbach mit seiner Republik auf
Martin sichert aus der afd-fraktion und
Bundestagsvizepräsident Kubicki der die
Leitung hier übernommen hat hat jetzt
anspult gerufen Tino Sorge den
gesundheitspolitischen Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Herr
Bundesminister Lauterbach als wir vor
der Sommerpause hier an dieser Stelle
standen haben sie uns versprochen es
würde im Hinblick auf die Pandemie
Bekämpfung im Herbst ein geordnetes
Verfahren geben das was wir erlebt haben
waren absurde Diskussion über die
maskenpflicht in Flugzeugen versus
maskenpflicht in der Bahn das was wir
erlebt haben waren 80 Seiten
Änderungsanträge vor der finalen
Ausschusssitzung wenige Stunden vorher
ein Kunde kann man das was sie hier als
geordnetes Verfahren angedeutet oder
angekündigt haben nur als Chaos am
verhandlungs-
und deshalb finde ich es auch so schade
dass heute wieder die Chance vertan wird
diesen Herbst so zu gestalten in seinem
Übergang in die Normalität mehr
Eigenverantwortung mehr Pragmatismus und
wenn Sie schon davon sprechen dass wir
europäische Harmonisierung wollen dann
schauen wir doch mal was die
europäischen Nachbarn machen dann lassen
Sie uns doch zumindest ansatzweise so
vorgehen wie das die europäischen
Nachbarn machen nämlich viel mehr
Pragmatismus statt Alarmismus und diese
Chance haben sie heute wieder vertan
Herr Kollege lauterbach
und was viel viel schlimmer an diesem
Gesetzentwurf ist dass er erhebliche
handwerkliche Mängel hat es ist ja
durchaus sinnvoll dass wir sagen
natürlich brauchen die Länder vor Ort
Maßnahmen die Länder brauchen
Möglichkeiten zu reagieren individuell
wie dann die Corona die pandemische Lage
vor Ort im Herbst sein sollte aber es
macht überhaupt keinen Sinn dass sie
nicht definieren unter welchen
Grundvoraussetzungen diese Maßnahmen
dann anwendbar sein sollen das wäre
genauso als wenn sie sagen die Länder
sollen mal den Verkehr regeln des Tempo
bestimmen aber gleichzeitig nicht
definieren ob jetzt rechts oder
Linksverkehr geht und das haben sie hier
wieder versäumt sie machen sich dazu
einfach liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Ampel
und was was viel viel schlimmer ist auch
angesichts der Diskussion die wir haben
bei der energiepreisdebatte und Herr
Kollege sie sind ja auch im
Energiesektor unterwegs das Problem ist
es brennt überall Lichter los sie lassen
die Kliniken allein die Ampel tut nichts
um den Kliniken finanziell unter die
Arme zu greifen und ich sage Ihnen jetzt
schon voraus es wird im Herbst
gefährlich für die Versorgung werden
falls es im Herbst zu weiteren
Schließung kommt und deshalb kann ich
sie nur appellieren die der Kollege und
Kollegen der Ampel lassen Sie die
Kliniken nicht im Stich Herr Kollege
Sorge erlauben sie inzwischen Frage des
Kollegen niemanden aber
selbstverständlich dass ich nicht so
Kollege sage ich Danke dass sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen ich würde gerne
eine Gegenfrage stellen können Sie mir
vielleicht berichten was die Länder
unter Unionsführung bisher unternommen
haben um die Krankenhäuser in dieser
Krise zu unterstützen
also lieber Herr Kollege Uhlmann
da wir ja sehr gut zusammenarbeiten auch
im Gesundheitsausschuss wundert mich
diese Frage sehr weil das ist ja im
Grunde die Diskussion die wir immer
haben dass dieses Ping Pong Spiel
zwischen Bund und Land kritisiert wird
insbesondere Bayern aber auch viele
andere Bundesländer haben ja bei der
Frage der
investitionskostenverpflichtung
erheblichen Nachholbedarf und deshalb
ist es ja auch so schade dass wir in der
Debatte jetzt wie wir diesen
Gesetzentwurf verbessern können nicht
nur in eigenen Antrag gestellt haben
einen eigenen Entschließungsantrag wir
haben Änderungsanträge gemacht wo wir
gesagt haben um die Kliniken zu
unterstützen beispielsweise im Vorsorge
und rehaeinrichtungsbereich wollen wir
unabhängig von der pandemischen Lage
zusätzliche
corona-sonderzahlung zulassen und das
haben sie mit dem Argument abgelehnt
dass man das nicht braucht und das
glaube ich ist ziemlich scheinheilig was
da passiert ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und deshalb will ich auch noch mal auf
einen Punkt Hinweisen um denen sie sich
in dem Gesetzentwurf und als Ampel als
Bundesregierung schon seit Monaten
herumdrücken das Thema
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
mittlerweile sagen die meisten Akteure
Krankenhäuser Pflegeheime
Wohlfahrtsverbände die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
brauchen wir nicht aber sie schweigen zu
dem Thema sie trauen sich nicht klar
Stellung zu nehmen und deshalb sagen wir
Ihnen als Union ganz deutlich wir können
uns keiner Personal Engpässe erlauben
die Verhältnismäßigkeit und
Notwendigkeit lassen sich nicht mehr
rechtfertigen darum fordern wir Sie
aufsetzen sie die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht aus besser heute als morgen
im Fazit kann man festhalten sie haben
heute wieder eine Chance vertan für den
Herbst einen wirklichen Plan auf den Weg
zu bringen stattdessen sehen wir
halbgare Kompromisse wir sind
Unklarheiten unklare Rechtsbegriffe es
wird zu einem Bürger führen
können hätten Sie unseren Anträgen
zugestimmt dann wäre alles besser
geworden vielen dank vielen Dank Herr
Kollege Sorge
als nächster Rednerin hält das Wort die
Kollegin Maria kleinschmalk wenn es 90
grün
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Haus es
ist gerade bei der Vorstellung durch den
Minister schon deutlich gemacht worden
wir gehen in diesem Herbst
handlungsfähig für den Ernstfall wir
verbinden Vorsorge und Schutz und
gleichzeitig achten wir darauf dass die
Schutzmaßnahmen so wenig eingreifend wie
irgend möglich sind und diese Kunst ist
uns gelungen obwohl wir als
Koalitionsfraktionen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Grundhaltungen kommen
das will ich an dieser Stelle eindeutig
festhalten und damit
sind wir sehr viel weiter als sie im
letzten Herbst uns hier die Republik
hinterlassen haben da hatten wir kein
Konzept da hatten wir keine vernünftige
impfstoffbeschaffung wir haben ganz ganz
schnell Aussehen rein des Parlamentes
für Schutz und Maßnahmen sorgen müssen
das war die Situation die sie uns
hinterlassen haben hier sind wir gehen
wir vorbereitet in den Herbst und so
dass man sagen kann mit Augenmaß und
gleichzeitig handlungsfähig
wir haben Nährstoffe parat wir haben
antivirale Medikamente parat die gerade
diejenigen die besonders gefährdet sind
schützen und wir haben einen
Maßnahmenkatalog und dieser
maßkartennamenkatalog wird gemäß in
Empfehlungen des expertenrats
Basismaßnahmen enthalten die bundesweit
gelten und durch die Länder zu
veranlassende Maßnahmen die darüber
hinausgehen können auch das entspricht
dem was die Wissenschaft uns empfohlen
hat in weiten Teilen und ich finde das
kann sich sehen lassen
und wenn hier die CDU redet von Übergang
in Normalität Pragmatismus
Eigenverantwortung wir hören das ja von
allen Seiten dann fehlen mir die anderen
Worte Verantwortung dafür zu übernehmen
dass wir es schaffen dass alle in dieser
Gesellschaft mitgehen können dass alle
in dieser Gesellschaft den notwendigen
Schutz erfahren den Sie brauchen und
dass wir dafür Sorge tragen dass es
keine Überlastung sowohl der wichtigen
Infrastrukturen im Gesundheitsbereich
als auch generell gibt und dass das
ein ganz ganz wichtiges Parameter ist
was wir im Hintergrund haben müssen ist
doch sehr sehr klar wir haben dieses
Jahr zwei umfangreiche Wellen erlebt die
unsere Krankenhäuser unsere Pflegeheime
unter Stress gestellt haben ohne Ende
das können wir und sollten wir im Winter
und im Herbst vermeiden so weit wir das
irgendwie können
und dann wurde hier angemerkt das sei
alles nicht konkret genug definiert im
übrigen hat die Sachverständige in der
Anhörung gesagt es ist eine bedeutend
bessere Konkretisierung und Definition
vorgelegt worden als das vorher der Fall
war und wir müssen natürlich ganz ganz
klar sagen
Omegon ist eine ganz andere Variante
corona-variante als die früheren
Varianten wir können nicht mit den
gleichen Schwellenwerten von damals
Arbeiten Schwellenwerte alleine werden
uns auch nicht den Weg aus dem Problem
führen auch das ist in diesem Gesetz
berücht berücksichtigt worden und da bin
ich sehr sehr dankbar dass wir mit den
Kriterien mit dem zusätzlichen
Monitoring der weiterschritte gehen
was wir in den nächsten Monaten im Blick
behalten müssen das wird ja auch zu
Recht angesprochen wir sind gewohnt dass
wir einen corona-schutzschirm hatten für
alle Einrichtungen der existiert in
dieser Art und Weise nicht mehr es
überlagern sich aber gleichzeitig
verschiedene Krisen insbesondere auch
die Energiekrise die große Auswirkungen
auf unsere Einrichtungen im
Gesundheitswesen haben wird da müssen
wir nachsteuern da werden wir jetzt auch
in den Haushaltsberatungen und im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren was entlang von
GKV-Finanzierung und Haushalt ansteht
noch mal hinschauen und sehr genau
schauen dass wir da zu Absicherung
kommen weil ganz klar ist wir nehmen
natürlich nicht in Kauf dass diese
wichtigen lebensnotwendigen
Infrastrukturen im Gesundheitswesen
gefährdet werden sondern natürlich geht
es um Versorgungssicherheit und
Sicherheit insgesamt in allen Dinslaken
da komme ich zu dem weiteren Punkt wir
haben die
kinderkrankengeldregelung weiter
fortgeführt die wir schon aus Corona
kannten weil für uns ist die Pandemie
nicht zu Ende wir müssen immer noch
damit rechnen dass es zu großen Wellen
kommt und natürlich ist es gerade für
die Familien eine ungeheure
Herausforderung wenn Sie
kinderkranke Kinder haben oder aber
Kinder die zu Hause bleiben müssen weil
sie infiziert sind dass sie das mit
ihrem Berufsleben auch vereinbaren
können da haben wir
Sicherungen gesorgt genauso wie für die
pflegenden Angehörigen auch die waren
uns ein ganz ganz großes Anliegen in so
einem Sinne wir haben hier
Frage der sie wer verantwortlich handeln
will guten Gewissens zustimmen können
eine Vorlage mit Augenmaß und
gleichzeitig mit einem Maximum an
Handlungsfähigkeit für den Fall dass
sich die Pandemie noch mal in größeren
Ausmaß als Bedrohung darstellt wir sind
gerüstet das ist genau richtig das ist
verantwortliches Handeln und das ist in
diesen Krisenzeiten ich meine auch ein
richtiges Signal Richtung Optimismus wir
wissen wir sind handlungsfähig und das
ist ein wichtiger Punkt dankeschön
nach nur wenigen alltagsauflagen im
Sommer sollen jetzt für Herbst und
Winter wieder mehr corona-schutzvorgaben
möglich sein der Bundestag will also ein
ganzes Gesetzespaket der Ampel dazu ja
heute beschließen und Maria
kleinschmalka ist angesprochen auch mit
darin nicht nur die Änderungen
Infektionsschutzgesetz sondern auch die
kinderkrankentage also wenn Eltern wegen
der Erkrankung eines Kindes zu Hause
bleiben bekommen sie als gesetzlich
Versicherte bis Ende 2023 weiterhin
zusätzliche kinderkrankentage pro Kind
wieder um den Schulbesuch zu ermöglichen
pro Kind Verzeihung sind es 30
Arbeitstage je Elternteil
[Applaus]
für die AFD jetzt
[Musik]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist Zeit den Betroffenen eine Stimme
zu geben ich zitiere ich schlief als ich
den schwersten Anruf meines Lebens bekam
der Arzt sagte dass das Herz meines
Vaters zu schlagen aufgehört habe wir
konnten uns nicht von ihm verabschieden
erst in der Leichenhalle begegne ich
meinem Vater wieder ich konnte nur auf
den leichten Sack starren da wegen der
ansteckungsfonds Gefahren nicht geöffnet
werden durfte als die Menschen vom
Bestattungsinstitut mein Vater abholten
trugen sie Schutzanzüge ich habe so
etwas noch nie gesehen
sie brachten ihn direkt ins Krematorium
ich konnte meinen Vater erst wieder in
den Arm nehmen als ich die Urne nach
Hause brachte
meine Damen und Herren geben Sie den
Menschen ihre Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung zurück vielen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Ziegler
ist für die Bundesregierung Herr
Bundesminister dokker dr Marko Buschmann
jetzt hier am Rednerpult es war ja in
bei diesen neuen corona-regeln auch
einen miteinander aber auch einen Ringen
zwischen Gesundheitsministerium und
Justizministerium
herr Präsident meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer die
fortschrittskoalition steht für eine
bessere corona-politik sie ist
transparenter sie ist parlamentarischer
sie stärkt den Grundsatz der
Verhältnismäßigkeit und die Grundrechte
das ist das Fazit dass der
Staatsrechtler Oliver Lepsius vor
wenigen Tagen in der Tageszeitung Die
Welt gezogen hat und dem es nicht
hinzuzufügen denn das ist die Wahrheit
meine sehr geehrten Damen und
wir haben die epidemische Lage von
nationaler Tragweite beendet noch bevor
wir eine Regierung gebildet haben und
wir haben im Frühjahr dieses Jahres fast
alle corona-schutzmaßnahmen beendet das
war damals sehr umstritten wir sind
Gegenstand von intensiver Kritik gewesen
aber mit dem Wissen von heute können wir
sagen dass es richtig war denn wir sind
gut durchs Frühjahr und gut durch den
Sommer gekommen und war ich bleibe bei
einem wenn es nicht nötig ist in
Grundrechte einzugreifen dann ist es
nötig nicht in Grundrechte einzugreifen
meine Damen und Herren
aber
und das gehört zu einer rationalen
Politik eben genauso dazu wenn uns eben
eine breite Gruppe an Experten fast alle
seriösen experten sagen dass man auch in
diesem Winter nicht sicher sagen kann
aber mit einer Verschärfung der Lager
rechnen muss dann sind wir es auch
schuldig den Staat handlungsfähig zu
machen und zwar auch in Abwägung mit
Verhältnismäßigkeit und Grundrechten und
genau das leistet dieser Gesetzentwurf
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
weil es dazu so viele falsch
Behauptungen und auch Missverständnisse
gibt will ich zu einzelnen Punkten ein
paar Anmerkungen machen um hierfür
Klarheit zu sorgen
wir beschließen heute über 28 Paragraph
bdsinfektionsschutzgesetzes der enthält
keine lockdowns keine Betriebsschließung
keine schuldschließung keine
Demonstrationsverbote und egal wie
häufig man es auf Twitter behauptet es
bleibt eine Lüge meine Damen und Herren
und wenn Leute auf den alten 28a
verweisen ich will den Hinweis geben das
ist die alte epidemische Lage von
nationaler Tragweite das hat diese
Koalition abgeschaltet und es müsste
sich schon die Hölle unter uns auftun
bis wir den anfassen das haben wir nicht
mehr in der schweren deltawelle im
letzten Winter getan das bitte ich
einfach mal zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und
lieber Herr Kollege Sorge ich finde es
ja gut dass sie sich für Maß halten bei
corona-schutzmaßnahmen einsetzen aber
sagen sie das mal bitte Ihren
Ministerpräsidenten das Bundesland
Bayern das Bundesland Hessen und das
mittlerweile leider schwarz-grüne
Bundesland Nordrhein-Westfalen haben
nach kontaktbeschränkungen und zwei G3
geht Zugangsbeschränkungen gerufen all
das machen wir nicht meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
ihr könnt zweitens ein Hinweis geben
weil ich immer wieder von
bundeseinheitlichen maskenpflichten in
Innenräumen lese wenn die Lage das
gebietet können Bundesländer
wahrscheinlich wenn es die Lage das
Gebieten würde würden es auch alle tun
zu seinem Instrument greifen aber das
einzige was der Bundesgesetzgeber
bundeseinheitlich qualitativ an
zusätzlichen Maßnahmen anordnet das ist
ein höherer Sicherheitsstandard in
Krankenhäusern Altenpflegeheimen
ambulanten Pflegeeinrichtungen ich will
mal eins sagen dort leben besonders
viele alte vulnerable und
schutzbedürftige Menschen die haben wir
in den vergangenen corona-wellen als
Stadt häufig im Stich gelassen und das
ist keine übermäßige Belastung wenn wir
unsere betagten kranken und alten Eltern
und Großeltern vor tot und Krankheit
schützen weil es eine verhältnismäßig
vernünftige Maßnahmen
will auch eins sagen im Gesetz stehen
Ermächtigungsgrundlagen für die Länder
damit können die Länder je nach Lage
verantwortungsbewusst umgehen es muss
kein Land wenn es der Meinung ist etwas
zu tun die Maske überall anwenden
sondern je nach Lage man kann das in
Behörden machen man kann auch Bereiche
rausnehmen und warum tun wir das weil
die Länder über zwei Jahre konkrete
pandemiebekämpfungserfahrung haben wer
wenn nicht die Länder vor Ort müssen
denn wissen ob man die Gastro rein oder
rausnehmen soll ob man die Hochschulen
rein oder rausnehmen sollen und das ist
vernünftig Gefahrenabwehr ist im
deutschen Föderalismus immer Ländersache
gewesen meine Damen und Herren
zwei Bemerkungen noch eine Bemerkung zur
Schule da haben wir am intensivsten
miteinander diskutiert denn eins ist
doch klar wenn es eine Gruppe gibt die
besonders gelitten hat in den letzten
Jahren dann waren es die Schülerinnen
und Schüler in diesem Land und deshalb
war das Recht auf Bildung und so
besonders wichtig und ich will mal das
was im Gesetz steht übersetzen dort
steht im Grundsatz es findet
Präsenzunterricht ohne Maske statt und
von diesem Grundsatz gibt es für die
jungen Schüler bis zur Grundschule keine
Ausnahme und wenn man für die älteren
Schüler eine Ausnahme machen will dann
nur wenn die Alternative wäre das kein
Präsenzunterricht mehr stattfindet ich
musste auch sagen es ist auch besser
wenn Schülerinnen und Schüler mit der
medizinischen Maske Präsenzunterricht
bekommen als wenn wir sie massenweise
nach Hause schicken müssen das ist doch
vernünftig meine Damen und Herren und
deshalb ich komme zum Schluss
wir können natürlich nicht ewig
weitermachen mit den an- und Abschalten
von Maßnahmen und natürlich wird Corona
ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt zum
allgemeinen Lebensrisiko gehören ob uns
das gefällt oder nicht und meine
persönliche Hoffnung ist meine
persönliche Hoffnung ist dass das der
letzte Winter mit corona-schutzmaßnahmen
war herzlichen Dank da sagt hier der
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann die
künftigen corona-bestimmungen im
Infektionsschutzgesetz die sollen gelten
vom 1 oktober bis siebten April
2023 und Marco Buschmann hat es ja noch
mal ausgeführt die Länder können
Vorgaben verhängen und bei kritischer
Lage auch ausweiten
Kathrin Vogler für die Linke jetzt die
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin
so Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ja die Bundesregierung ist nicht zu
beneiden
fortschreitende Klimakrise Inflation
Angriffskrieg Putins gasanbare und dann
auch wenn wir es wirklich nicht mehr
hören können immer noch und immer wieder
Corona so viele Baustellen so viel
drängender Handlungsbedarf aber
wenigstens am letzten Punkt da haben
doch viele Leute gehofft dass es jetzt
im dritten Pandemie ja mit einem Karl
Lauterbach als Gesundheitsminister mal
nicht erst auf den letzten Drücker ein
Halbjahres Maßnahmen moogspaket durchs
Parlament gepeitscht wird sondern das
frühzeitig geplant und sorgfältig
beraten wird alle die wurden schmerzlich
enttäuscht und
Herr Minister Buschmann wenn sie sagen
wir seien gut durch den Sommer gekommen
was sagen sie den Angehörigen der 3000
über 3000 Menschen die in diesem Juli an
Corona oder mit Corona verstorben sind
was viel viel mehr sind das ungefähr das
zählt mehr als das Zehnfache von dem ist
was im Juli 2020 und im Juli 2021 an
Todesfällen ja was sagen sie denn
und Herr Minister Lauterbach sie sagen
wir sind sehr sehr gut vorbereitet
ich glaube nicht ich frage mich zum
Beispiel beim dritten pandemie-sommer
warum im dritten Pandemie soll man diese
Bundesregierung nicht die Gelegenheit
genutzt hat die Schulen nicht nur verbal
in ihrem Gesetzentwurf auf den Winter-
und Herbst vorzubereiten sondern
tatsächlich mit Luftfiltern und mit
einer Strategie dass die versprochene
Verhinderung von Schulschließungen und
Fernunterricht hat sich hier umgesetzt
werden kann das frage ich mich doch also
ja offensichtlich haben sie sich ja
lange nicht einigen können sie haben uns
dann sehr kurzfristig umfangreiche
Änderungen noch mal zu ihrem eigenen
Gesetzentwurf auf den Tisch gelegt und
dann haben sie aber noch auf die Lobby
gehört das kann man doch niemandem
erzählen dass man in Nahverkehrszügen
vielleicht
in Fernverkehrszügen ja aber in
Flugzeugen keine Maske tragen muss und
Herr Lauterbach sie waren ja ganz
ehrlich zu uns im Gesundheitsausschuss
das fand ich wirklich beeindruckend sie
haben uns genau beschrieben wie die
Lobbyisten von der Lufthansa AG zu Ihnen
in die Bundesregierung gekommen sind und
gesagt haben ja das ist alles so
schrecklich kompliziert und unsere unser
personales belastet mit der Durchsetzung
der maskenpflicht und vielleicht
verzögern sich dadurch auch Flüge ja
meinen Sie denn im Fernverkehr das
Personal ist nicht belastet mit der
Durchsetzung der maskenpflicht die Leute
in Bussen und Bahnen die da eigentlich
nur die Fahrkarten vielen Dank die sind
nicht belastet davon es werden noch
jetzt die nächsten Anforderungen kommen
und die nächsten Lobbyisten bei Ihnen
für ein und ausgehen in der Tür was ist
denn das für eine Bundesregierung was
ist denn das für eine Bundesregierung wo
der Finanzminister sich von Porsche die
e-fuels in den Koalitionsvertrag
schreiben lässt der
Wirtschaftsminister sich die gasumlage
von den Energiekonzernen diktieren lässt
und der Gesundheitsminister der
luftverkehrslobby einknickt und den
gesundheitsschutzopfert also Herr
Lauterbach dass es keine gute
Vorbereitung es ist nicht konsistent und
es ist auch nicht so es ist auch nicht
so dass es nur verwirrend und
unplausibel klingt es ist unplausibel
und das wird es den Menschen wahnsinnig
schwer machen wir haben ihn ein zehn
Punkteplan vorgelegt mit guten Maßnahmen
langfristig zu planen und so
implementieren beispielsweise eine
Teststrategie eine bessere Kommunikation
übers impfen das haben sie alles
ignoriert und liegen lassen also ich
spielte es ihnen noch mal an wir werden
uns bestimmt noch mal sehen hier zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz vor dem Ende des
Jahres nehmen Sie unsere sehr guten
Punkte auf und kümmern Sie sich darum
dass die Menschen in diesem Land sicher
sein können diesen Maßnahmen notspaket
werden wir nicht zustimmen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Vogler
das nächste wird dann hat das Wort die
kolleginese hat paradari SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren können Sie sich
noch an den September letzten Jahres
erinnern
in unserer schnelllebigen Zeit vergessen
wir wie es damals um die Vorbereitung
auf die zu erwartenden Steigerung der
Krone Infektionszahlen stand wir waren
nicht gut vorbereitet haben aber dazu
gelernt das folgende Gesetzespaket mit
einem abgestuften Instrumentenkasten
gibt einen richtigen Rahmen für die
pandemiebekämpfung vor
laut dem struckschen Gesetz verlässt
kein Gesetzesentwurf dem Bundestag so
wie es reingekommen ist auch in diesem
Falle ist es uns Abgeordneten gelungen
einen Kompromiss innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition zu erzählen um vulnerable
Gruppen zu schützen und unser
Gesundheitssystem vor Überlastung auch
zu schützen
als Abgeordnete im Parlament und Ärztin
musste ich lernen dass sie reine
medizinische Lehre nicht eins zu eins in
Gesetzestexte übernommen werden kann die
Herausforderung besteht darin die
Alltagsrealität der Menschen und die
Umsetzbarkeit unserer Gesetze im Fokus
zu haben und das ist uns mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetzesentwurf gut
gelungen im laufenden Prozess
im laufenden Prozess sind wir immer
wieder auf Anregungen von Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern von Fachverbänden auch
pediatrischen Verbänden und
Wissenschaftlern eingegangen und haben
diese Perspektiven einfließen lassen
insbesondere als Kinderärztin bin ich
froh dass wir im vorliegenden
Gesetzesvorschlag zwei wichtige Aspekte
im Sinne unserer Eltern gut regeln
konnten erstens die corona-infektion ist
nicht laut Paragraph 34
Infektionsschutzgesetz meldepflichtig
geworden das ist eine große
Erleichterung so müssen Kinder bzw ihre
Eltern weder bei Verdacht noch bei
durchgemachter Infektion jedes mal ein
herzliches Attest für den Kindergarten
bzw Schule erbringen nach 30 Monaten der
Pandemie in denen gerade die jüngsten
unserer Gesellschaft und ihre Familien
eine große soziale Last zu tragen hatten
hätte ich dies nicht für angemessen
gehalten
daher bin ich überaus glücklich dass wir
diese Verschärfung der Regelung aus dem
Gesetz streichen konnten liebe Eltern es
wird einfacher
zweitens aus meiner praktischen
Erfahrung weiß ich wie wichtig und wie
hilfreiche das Instrument der
sogenannten kindertranke
kinderkrankentagegeldregelung für viele
berufstätige Eltern ist es ermöglicht
den Familien sich nicht selber
krankschreiben lassen zu müssen Eltern
können bis Ende 2023 30 Tage und
Alleinerziehende 60 Tage beanspruchen
dies ist genau der richtige Schritt für
die Verbesserung der Situation von
Familien
die Kinder und Jugendlichen haben in der
Pandemie gelitten das zeigen uns
zahlreiche Studien wie die
kopfstiestudien und der Kinder- und
jugendreporter DRK
angesichts dieser Entwicklung ist es zur
Stützung der psychischen Gesundheit von
Kindern und Jugendlichen auch die
absolut richtige Entscheidung und das
richtige Signal Schulen und Kitas in
jedem Fall offen zu halten wir müssen
und werden es den jüngsten der
Gesellschaft unter den gegebenen
Umständen so live wie möglich machen an
Bildung zu partizipieren und am sozialen
Leben teilzuhaben
wir folgen nicht populistischen
Kampagnen wir folgen dem klaren Ziel
dieses Land und unser Gesundheitssystem
auf Basis niedrigschwilliger
verlässlicher Maßnahmen in einem
abgestuften Plan auch mit
länderverantwortlichkeiten durch den
kommenden Winter zu bringen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die Pandemie
ist nicht vorbei auch wenn wir uns das
wünschen oder einreden mögen daher
müssen wir gut präpariert sein packen
wir es an vielen herzlichen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegen in
Simone Borchert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
mehr Selbstbestimmung und weniger
Regulierungen das muss unsere Prämisse
sein die anderen Länder innerhalb der EU
machen als uns vor wir brauchen weniger
Gängelung und endlich Maßnahmen die auf
wissenschaftlich fundierte Daten
aufbauen wer sich heute führt gegen
diesen Virus schützen will der kann das
bereits sehr eigenverantwortlich für
sich selbst entscheiden indem er
freiwillig eine Maske trägt und sich
freiwillig impfen lässt schaffen Sie
bitte endlich klare und nachvollziehbare
Vorgaben für den Herbst und Winter die
Bevölkerung die Wirtschaft und besonders
die kleinen mittelständischen
Unternehmen wäre es Ihnen danken und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mit der Ampel schaffen Sie bitte endlich
die einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht ab
diese ist nicht umsetzbar um belastet
die betroffenen Einrichtungen mit
unnötiger Bürokratie sie belastet die
Beschäftigten und sorgt für Probleme bei
der Personalgewinnung und vor allem bei
der Personal Einsatzplanung und in
diesem Zusammenhang ist es auch sinnvoll
über die quarantäne-regelung
nachzudenken denn die ist so wie sie
jetzt ist auch nicht mehr zeitgemäß
und zu versuchen sie auch nicht an die
Folgen ihres Handelns das hat der
Aufschrei der Kinder- und jugendärzte
dieser zeigt letzte Woche und es wurde
ausdrücklich vor den Folgen gewarnt koit
19 in den Katalog
der Kranz zu nehmen das hätte
schwerwiegende Folgen für die Praxen
gehabt aber anstatt dem Ausschuss
unserem Änderungsantrag zuzustimmen
schaffen sie wieder eine zusatzregelung
mit umfangreichen Testungen
und leider haben Sie auch schon im
Frühjahr unseren Antrag auf Einrichtung
eines impfregisters abgelehnt sie haben
schon im Frühjahr unsere Forderungen
nach frühzeitiger vor allem Verbesserung
der Datenlage und dem Aussetzen der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
abgelehnt und es gibt bis heute keine
kohärente datenerfassungsstrategie
stattdessen müssen wir sogar an der
Presse lesen dass sie Daten zur
Immunität in der Bevölkerung erst Ende
September herausgeben wollen und das
nach Abstimmung in diesen Plenum zu
diesem Gesetz und eigentlich sollte es
ja umgedreht sein die Politik sollte der
Wissenschaft folgen nur leider erleben
wir es wieder genau andersrum und das
ist keine Art und Weise mit solchen
Themen umzugehen
Vertrauen gegenüber der Bevölkerung ist
für uns wesentlich zielführender und
effektiver als jede Pflicht die sie hier
gerade schaffen wollen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich fordere Sie daher
auf stimmen Sie unserem Antrag zu
ermöglichen sie endlich mehr
Selbstbestimmung vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Dr
Janosch damit Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Gesundheitsausschuss für die Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen Kolleginnen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die als gestern heute
zuschauen es ist schon erstaunlich in
welchem atemberaubenden Tempo die Union
sich von einem wissenschaftsbasierten
Kurs verabschiedet hat da werden
Nebelkerzen geworfen fehlende
Datengrundlage Verabschiedung von
wissenschaftlichen Kurs ich kann weder
in der vorliegenden Gesetzesnovelle
erkennen ja worauf sie sich da beziehen
noch wie ihre Anträge dazu beitragen
sollen dem Expertenrat den Empfehlungen
von wissenschaftrechnung zu tragen
sondern muss vielmehr sagen es ist heiße
Luft was hier an Oppositionsarbeit
gemacht wird es gibt sicher Fehler die
in der Pandemie passieren und die
kritisiert werden können aber das was
hier vorgelegt wird ist weder eine
Alternative noch trägst dazu bei dass
die Akzeptanz für das was gemeinsam im
zusammenstehen zur Bewältigung der Krise
getan werden muss wirklich nach vorne
gestellt wird
Zwischenfrage aus der CDU-Fraktion
konnte sie nicht verstehen erwarten Sie
Ihre erlauben sie inzwischen Frage aus
der cdu/cs
lieber sehr geschätzte Kollege Janosch
Damen danke dass du die Zwischenfrage
zulässt meine Frage ist da du ja von
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
gesprochen hast wie argumentiert du
wissenschaftlich dass man die
maskenpflicht im Flugzeugen abschafft
und im Fernverkehr beibehält
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Zeuner für die
Frage die gibt mir die Gelegenheit noch
mal aufzuklären wie es zu dieser
Vereinbarung gekommen ist und warum wir
an dieser Stelle hier das Gesetz
weiterentwickeln selbstverständlich
interessiert sich das Virus nicht
selbstverständlich interessiert sich das
Virus nicht dafür ob es sich bei einem
Menschen in der Bus Bahn Auto oder wo
auch immer verbreitet sondern überall wo
Menschen gerade im Innenraum
zusammenkommen besteht weiterhin ein
hohes Risiko sich einzustecken deswegen
ist es richtig dort Maske zu tragen und
sich selbst und andere zu schützen
gleichwohl tragen wir mit diesem
gesetzrechnung dass wir dort wo wir
grenzüberschreitenden Flugverkehr haben
Regeln anpassen an das was im übrigen
Europa als überwiegender Standard gilt
und erhalten uns über eine
Rechtsverordnung weiter die Möglichkeit
darauf zu reagieren sollte sich die Lage
zu verschlimmern auch hier die
maskenpflicht wieder einzuführen das
heißt gerade als Arzt kann ich nur
appellieren weiter auch Maske tragen im
Flugzeug auch wenn wir die Regeln hier
an europ Wünsche übrige Regeln anpassen
das hat aber nichts damit zu tun dass
das unwissenschaftlich ist sondern eine
Harmonisierung gerade auch im Sinne der
Nachvollziehbarkeit die von Ihnen hier
wiederholt eingefüllt eingefordert wurde
lassen Sie mich lassen Sie mich aber
zurückkommen zu dem was eigentlich zu
tun ist und ich glaube es es ist
entscheidend noch mal auf die vier
Punkte zurückzukommen die der
ministereingang nach vorne gestellt hat
es ist jetzt entscheidend dass wir die
verbliebenen Wochen bis zum Herbst wenn
die Menschen im Innenraum wieder
zustande kommen nutzen nochmal Vollgas
zu geben mit einer auffrisch
Impfkampagne die wir brauchen in diesem
Land mit neuen Impfstoffen die wir in
ausreichender Zahl beschafft haben die
explizit davor schützen dass Menschen
die besonders gefährdet sind auch mit
diesen neuen Virustypen schwer erkranken
und auch das Risiko anderer anzustecken
nach geltener Daten legen deutlich
reduziert wird wir werden das mit einer
breit angelegten Kampagne um genau dafür
zu werden um die Menschen aufzuklären
nochmal in den Vordergrund stellen und
wir werden das ist Punkt zwei eben nicht
nur Impfstoffe sondern auch die
Medikamente einsetzen um schwere
Krankheiten zu verhindern es ist ja
richtig was angesprochen wurde hier in
der Debatte das ist ausgesprochen
bekümmerlich ist dass wir in einem
Sommermonat Juli 3000 Menschen erneut
wegen Corona verloren haben in diesem
Land und hier gezielt Medikamente
einzusetzen und ich kann Ihnen nur
erraten gehen Sie in die
Pflegeeinrichtung gehen sie dort wo
organisierte Wohnformen vulnerable
Gruppen beheimaten hin und fragen Sie
mal nach sind hier Menschen gestorben
schwer erkrankt und wie häufig wurden
solche Medikamente die ja seit vielen
Monaten zur Verfügung stehen bisher
eingesetzt sie werden feststellen viel
zu selten und das ist skandalös es geht
um jedes Leben was wir hier retten
können was wichtig ist und deshalb
setzen wir diese Medikamente durch
gestärkte Unterstützung und Regeln
entsprechend auch ein dritter Punkt
anders als es hier von der Union gerade
behauptet wurde verbessern wir die
Datengrundlage wir führen ein
pandemierer Radar ein der endlich dafür
sorgt dass wir eben nicht nur einen
Indikator haben sondern ein großes Maß
an Datentransparenz die dafür sorgt
Versorgung im Gesundheitswesen
kapazitätsüberblick verstärkt in den
Blick zu nehmen indem wir betreibbare
Betten nicht nur auf den
Intensivstationen erfassen sondern auch
auf den normalstationen indem wir durch
ein Anschluss an das Notaufnahme
Register umfassende Daten zur
Notfallversorgung erfassen als Sentinel
Programm als warenprogramm und
frühzeitig festzustellen was passiert
indem wir abwassermonitoring zusammen
mit den Ländern flächendeckend einführen
neue Virusvarianten gegebenenfalls
frühzeitig feststellen können das ist
wissenschaftsgetrieben das ist
datengetriebene Politik die gezielt
darauf reagiert wo es Gefahren gibt und
wo Maßnahmen greifen müssen und letzter
Punkt die Novelle des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes ist eben keine
die dort ansetzt wo Maßnahmen haben
ungezielt zu einem Zeitpunkt wenn die
Lage eskaliert erst greifen sondern sie
setzt da an mit einfachen wirkungsvollen
Maßnahmen in der Breite nämlich Masken
die Menschen vor Infektionen schützen
die dafür sorgen dass wir es gar nicht
in die Situation kommen wie im letzten
Herbst wo ein unions geführter
Gesundheitsminister erst reagiert hat
und erst bereit war wirklich für
konsequente Maßnahmen zu sorgen als die
Lage viel zu schlimm war als Masken
allein nicht mehr gereicht haben das
machen wir anders ein breiter
Basisschutz eine Rechtsgrundlage die den
Ländern ermöglicht wenn es erforderlich
ist gezielt regional zu reagieren
Einheitlichkeit bedeutet nicht
Gleichzeitigkeit sondern bedeutet
gezielte Steuerung und dem tragen wir
mit einem gezielten Gesetz hier
entsprechend Rechnung in diesem Sinne
lassen sie mich zum Schluss kommen die
Pandemie ist nicht vorbei und wir haben
sehr wohl wir haben sehr wohl gehört
dass dort wo Kliniken in aktuell
wirtschaftlich schwierige Situationen
kommen wo Pflegeeinrichtungen wo
Rehakliniken gesagt haben wir haben
wirtschaftliche Probleme dass wir dort
reagieren werden aber nicht im
Infektionsschutzgesetz sondern im Rahmen
der Haushaltsberatung des
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz und
gegebenenfalls auch eines
Rettungspaketes für Sozialwesen wo wir
uns darum kümmern werden genau gezielt
auf die Not die dort ist auch
entsprechend zu reagieren
zum Schluss die Pandemie die Pandemie
hat uns die Pandemie hat uns jetzt im
dritten Jahr allen viel Arten und wir
sollten dafür sorgen dass wir angesichts
der multiplen Krisen die uns darüber
hinaus begleiten gezielt an dieser
Stelle auch darauf reagieren dass wir
die Lage erst hier gar nicht schlimmer
werden lassen das liefert dieses Gesetz
in diesem Sinne stimmen Sie unseren
Antrag zu ich kann sie von der
Opposition angesichts der teilweise
fragwürdigen Vorschläge dazu auffordern
vielen Dank
die maskenpflicht bundesweit soll in
Kliniken in Pflegeheimen und in
Arztpraxen auch ab 1 Oktober weiterhin
gelten das gilt beispielsweise auch für
Fernzüge im Flugverkehr wird die
maskenpflicht entfallen darauf hatte ja
vor allem die FDP gedrungen die
neuregeln betrifft innerdeutsche Flüge
sowie Flüge aus und in Deutschland auch
aus Deutschland und nach Deutschland es
ist Zeit der Betroffenen eine Stimme zu
geben mit Erlaubnis des Präsidenten
zitiere ich eine Krankenschwester
seit einiger Zeit arbeite ich in einer
psychosomatischen Klinik dort habe ich
erlebt die von einem Tag auf den anderen
200 Patienten von zwei Wochen in ihrer
Zimmer eingesperrt worden weil eine
Mitarbeiterin positiv getestet wurde das
krasseste dabei ist das Gesundheitsamt
ordnete die Quarantäne an dem Tag an als
noch Patienten anreisten man stelle sich
vor es kommen psychisch kranke Menschen
in eine Klinik um dort eine Therapie zu
machen und werden als erstes in ihrer
Zimmer eingesperrt
dieser Zustände wollen wir nie wieder
erleben meine Damen und Herren geben Sie
den Menschen ihre Freiheit und ihre
Eigenverantwortung zurück
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dietz Thomas
[Applaus]
Köhler FDP-Fraktion und Lukas Köhler ist
der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Liberalen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eins der
schwierigsten Unterfangen und eines der
wichtigsten und erfangenen Demokratie
ist das Abwägen das Abwägen zwischen
Freiheit und Sicherheit das Abwägen
zwischen Eigenverantwortung und Schutz
und
ab und zu ist es auch ein schwieriges
Unterfangen eine gemeinsame Position zu
finden zum Glück ist das hierbei nicht
der Fall gewesen zum Glück haben die
Minister sich gut einigen können zum
Glück haben wir in dieser Situation uns
als regierungstreibende
Koalitionsfraktionen und das ist glaube
ich ein großer Vorteil umso mehr
verwundert mich das was die Union heute
hier macht und das was die Union in den
letzten Tagen gemacht haben und bei der
AFD wundert mich nichts mehr aber diese
diese Kakophonie aus unterschiedlichen
Stimmen das was wieder auf der einen
Seite sagen das was sie jetzt heute hier
in ihren Reden sagen das ist doch schon
sehr verwunderlich glaube Sie sollten
sich mal zusammensetzen und mal noch mal
darüber nachdenken was sie so mit der
corona-pandemie für eine Position
vertreten wenn ich mir und wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere und letztens als ich
nachgeguckt habe sehr
Gesundheitsminister aus Bayern immer
noch Teil der CSU und der scheut im
Moment kein einziges Mikrofon in dem er
nach neuen härteren schärferen Maßnahmen
schreit es ist verwunderlich wenn ich
mir das anhören was ich hier von ihnen
aufgetischt bekomme auf der anderen
Seite hören wir hier gerade das
quarantäne-regelnden Problem sind naja
Paragraph 30 Infektionsschutzgesetz
liebe Kolleginnen die Länder können das
ganz einfach ändern ich erwarte also
nach dem heutigen Tag eine Änderung in
den Bundes in den Bundesländern die von
der Union geführt werden nach der
anderen ich freue mich darauf dass sie
den Worten die sie hier so zahlreich
verkünden auch Taten folgen lassen das
wird glaube ich ein wahres Fest der
Demokrat ist glaube ich auf der richtige
Schritt und Frau Kolleginnen Vogtland
sie hatten ja gerade die Lufthansa
angesprochen was mich ein bisschen
wundert ich dachte immer die Linke wäre
sehr eng verwandelt mit der Gewerkschaft
und jetzt ist meine Position als FDP da
ja oft nicht immer die gleiche die die
Gewerkschaft einnimmt aber die
Gewerkschaften waren die ersten die
gesagt haben es ist gut für die Menschen
in den Flieger die da arbeiten arbeiten
müssen dass sie nicht die ganze Zeit
Maske tragen ich bin ein bisschen
verwundert ich bin ein bisschen
verwundert was hier passiert meine Damen
und Herren das Infektionsschutzgesetz
tut exakt das was es tun soll es
verbindet Eigenverantwortung und Schutz
und zwar genauso wie es richtig ist auf
der einen Seite so viel
Eigenverantwortung so viel Freiheit wie
möglich und auf der anderen Seite so
viel Schutz wie nötig und ich glaube da
ist uns was wirklich gutes gelungen denn
die Menschen haben andere Sorgen in
diesem Winter das wollen wir auch
ehrlich sagen die Leute sorgen sich vor
den hohen Preisen die Leute sorgen sich
vor der Inflation und ich glaube mit
diesem Gesetz sind sie sind wir alle gut
darauf vorbereitet wir die nächsten
Monate miteinander gestalten vielen Dank
für an die Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
natürlich auch für dieses Gesetz
wollen sie Zwischenfragen zugelassen das
sind wir über ein Video wieder
rausgeholt aber es ist leider zu spät so
also
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Dr
Christina Baum afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr Präsident Heidi Fischer ist eine
autistische Frau und sie schrieb eine
Mail an alle Mitglieder des
Gesundheitsausschusses es war ja
ausdrücklicher Wunsch dass ich heute
daraus zitiere Zitat ich schreibe Ihnen
weil ich aufgrund meiner Behinderung und
meines Autismus mit den ganzen
corona-maßnahmen überhaupt gar nicht
klarkomme und weil mir diese Maßnahmen
sehr extrem riesengroße Angst und Panik
machen ich habe sehr extrem riesengroße
Probleme dass ich bei meinem Gegenüber
durch die Masken überhaupt gar keine
Mimik und Gestik sehen kann mich
irritieren und verwirren diese Masken
vor dem Gesicht meiner Mitmenschen
Umarmungen streichel und
Kuscheleinheiten und anderer liebevoller
Körperkontakt muss sehr dringend und
sehr schnell wieder möglich sein Zitat
Ende geben Sie den Menschen ihre
Freiheit und ihre Selbstbestimmung
zurück
vielen Dank als nächste Redner hat das
Wort nachdem ich ihn aufgerufen habe der
Kollege Dr Andreas Philippi SPD-Fraktion
der schnell am Rednerpult war für die
SPD-Fraktion ist er im
Gesundheitsausschuss
Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuhörerinnen und
Zuhörer
gestatten Sie mir eine Bemerkung
zu diesem
Spiel was sie hier machen mit ihren
sieben mal eine Minute spielen
ich höre sehr wohl zu ich habe sehr
viele von diesen Menschen behandelt das
was sie hier machen entlarvt sich
nämlich das entlarvt sich nämlich ganz
deutlich wenn man die taz wenn man die
taz von gestern liest und hört
dahinter frieren dass kein Gas da ist
sie haben sich entlarvt und das gleiche
tun sie auch wenn Sie ein freiheitstag
wünschen sie nehmen willigen den Kauf
dass Menschen frieren sterben sie hassen
dieses Land sie sind partnerlose
Gesellen vaterlandslose Gesellschaft
Kollege Herr Kollege Philippi bei aller
bewürdigung der Emotionen die hin und
her gehen wir sollten uns mit Kategorien
die vatertagslose Gesellschaft anderes
nicht traktieren im Deutschen Bundestag
sie haben das Wort ja Kollege
zeichnet sich dadurch aus wie mit den
schwächsten wie man mit dem ihren
schwächsten umgeht wie man mit den
vulnerablen verletzlichen Gruppen in
ihrer ja sie sind eine schwache Gruppe
ja in ihrer Mitte umgeht und diese vor
Krankheit schwerer Krankheit und sogar
tödlicher Krankheit oder auch vor
langwierigen Folgen von Erkrankungen
schützt
wir fragen uns wie finanzieren wir unser
Gemeinwesen und schützen unseren
Wohlstand und noch grundlegender wie
sichern wir eine gute und gesunde
Zukunft für uns alle wie gelingt der
Spagat zwischen persönlichen
Freiheitsrechten und
gesamtgesellschaftlicher Solidarität wir
haben aus 30 Monaten Pandemie gelernt
und unser politisches Handeln angepasst
die ampelkollekt die Ampelkoalition hat
sich vorbereitet und denkt auch an
Eventualitäten und Notfälle wir
übernehmen damit Verantwortung für die
Menschen hier in unserem Land das meine
Damen und Herren macht gute Politik aus
und genau dieses Motto steckt in unserem
Gesetzentwurf für die Stärkung des
Schutzes der Bevölkerung gegen covid 19
gegen die kovit 19 Pandemie unser Ziel
ist es Überlastung von Notaufnahmen
Kliniken und Intensivstationen zu
unser Ziel ist es die Kräfte der
Pflegenden zu schonen und unser Ziel ist
es die Sterblichkeit durch covid 19
weiter deutlich zu senken und Last
und last but not least die
Funktionsfähigkeit von kritischer
Infrastruktur damit meine ich nicht die
Parteizentrale der CDU zu gewährleisten
mit diesem mit diesem Gesetzentwurf der
von Oktober der von Oktober bis Ostern
gelten soll
sind wir gut auf den Winter vorbereitet
mit einem neuen angepassten politischen
Instrumentenkasten statten wir Bund und
Länder aus um auf weitere pandemische
Entwicklungen zielgenauzügig aber auch
maßvoll reagieren zu können meine Leiter
erkrankte Kollegin Heike Behrens der ich
von hier aus ich denke im Namen aller
gute Besserung wünsche hätte heute
gesagt
hätte heute gesagt niemand will
Schneeketten anlegen wenn die Straße
eisfrei ist aber wenn wir im Winter in
die Berge fahren sollten die Ketten im
Kofferraum bereit liegen
was ist also neue was ist anders was
haben wir gelernt hier drei kurze
Beispiele wir sind pragmatischer
geworden und haben die Kritik der
kindeärzte aufgenommen und keine
umständliche Gesundschreibung Frau
Kollegin barradary hatte schon erwähnt
von Kindern mehr ein negativer Test
reicht aus zweitens wir sind zielgenauer
geworden und haben die
ffp2-maskenpflicht über die Bereiche der
Pflegeheime und Krankenhäuser hinaus nun
bundeseinheitlich auf die Arztpraxen die
erlöser-einrichtung und den
Rettungsdienst ausgedehnt
wo sich potenziell kranke Menschen
nahekommen soll Schutz der Schutz erhöht
werden ich komme zum Schluss ein letzter
Satz dann sind wie effektiv Masken die
Ansteckung verhindern zeigen die
geringen Inzidenzen bei Influenza und
rs-
Herr Kollege ich habe ihn gerade das
Wort entzogen ich kann bei der
afd-fraktion nicht auf die Redezeit
achten und sie überziehen 30 Sekunden
[Applaus]
als nächster Redner hat das Wort der
Kollege Frank Rink afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
danke Herr Präsident Werte Kollegen alle
Argumente die dagegen sprechen wurden
von unserer Fraktion hier schon
vorgebracht darum zitiere ich heute
Klaus Stöhr Virologe und
Epidemiologe vom 27.06 diesen Jahres aus
der Frankfurter Rundschau aktuell ist
die Bundesregierung eher im panikmodus
unterwegs um es ganz klar zu sagen
Masken tragen und Abstand halten ist
gegenwärtig nicht notwendig
es gibt keine Anzeichen für eine
Überlastung des Gesundheitswesens und
das schiebt außerdem nur die Infektion
nach hinten verhindern wird man sie
sowieso nicht ebenfalls Klaus Stöhr am
dritten siebten diesen Jahres der
Standard notwendig sind einschränkende
Maßnahmen dann wenn das Allgemeinwohl
gefährdet ist doch das ist aktuell bei
Corona nicht mehr der Fall meine Damen
und Herren Dr Philippi geben Sie in
Menschen ihre Freiheit und ihre
Selbstbestimmung zurück vielen Dank
was willst Du reden
als nächster Redner das Wort der Kollege
Dr Georg Kippel CDU-Fraktion
sehr Präsident verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wir steuern jetzt auf den dritten
corona-wind dazu und es kann ein guter
Winter werden oder besser gesagt es
könnte ein guter Winter werden wenn das
was die Ampel im
Infektionsschutzgesetz vorschlägt auch
wirklich greift wir haben eine Menge von
Informationen aus den letzten
zweieinhalb Jahren auch Erfahrungen mit
erfolgen bzw mit einem entscheidenden
Kriterium das für die Wirksamkeit dieses
Gesetzes von Bedeutung ist nämlich die
Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung bei den
Schilderungen von Bundesminister
Lauterbach haben wir eben einen bunten
Strauß von
eventualmaßnahmen wenn dann und auch
gegebenenfalls warum als nächstes gehört
und vernommen und diese hochkomplexe
Schachtelung von verschiedenen Maßnahmen
unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen ist
bedauerlicherweise alles andere als
geeignet die Akzeptanz und die
Vorhersehbarkeit
der
Bevölkerung herbeizuführen und der
Hinweis dass sich unter Umständen aus
den lokalen Unterschieden in den
einzelnen Bundesländern veränderte
Betrachtungen ergeben ja das Christ dem
Grunde nach vielleicht zutreffend aber
wir dürfen nicht übersehen dass der Weg
vom Wohnort zum Arbeitsplatz in ein
anderes Bundesland führen kann und
insofern die Praktikabilität und damit
auch die Akzeptanz schwindet was mir
aber ganz besonders aufgefallen ist ist
das sowohl in den Ausführungen von
Minister Lauterbach als auch von meinen
Kollegen Janosch Dahmen der Wert und die
Umsetzung der Impfung jetzt mit den
neuen Impfstoffen einen sehr großen
Stellenwert eingenommen hat der Nutzen
der Impfung ist jedenfalls bei mir und
bei der cdu/csu-fraktion vollkommen
außer Frage aber wir haben Anfang des
Jahres feststellen müssen dass die
Akzeptanz für die Impfung flächendeckend
in der Bevölkerung nur sehr schwer oder
möglicherweise in bestimmten Bereichen
nicht erreicht werden kann so dass auf
Artland Weise eben eine sofortige Lösung
des
corona-pandemie-problems nicht
gewährleistet werden kann und es sollte
jedenfalls auch nicht indirekt der
Versuch unternommen werden
gewissermaßen über eine Impfpflicht
durch die Hintertür zu suggerieren dass
dies das Allheilmittel ist die Impfung
ist wertvoll wichtig und sie sollte
immer wieder fortgeschrieben und
empfohlen werden aber ihre
Werthaltigkeit muss bei der Bevölkerung
auch klar betont werden dass eben die
Akzeptanz für dieses Reaktionsmittel
unbedingt wichtig ist arbeiten Sie
deshalb in der weiteren
Umsetzung dieses Gesetzes maßgeblich
dafür weil wir nicht wissen in welchem
Stadium in welcher Stufe wir uns mit der
corona-pandemie in den nächsten Wochen
Monaten oder auch vielleicht Jahren
beschäftigen müssen und als Schlusssatz
noch die Bemerkung sehr der Minister ein
gutes Gesetz wird nicht deshalb ein
gutes Gesetz der Ampel wenn sie mit und
Kollegen Buschmann einig in der
Pressekonferenz
Pressekonferenz sitzen dazu gehört mehr
und deshalb leben wir das Gesetz ab
vielen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Carolin Bachmann afd-fraktion
herr Präsident
wir geben den Betroffenen eine Stimme
die traurige Mutter von Lea mein Mann
und ich haben der Regierung geglaubt und
uns gegen Corona impfen lassen weil wir
sozial sein wollten auch die Freundinnen
unserer Tochter waren bereits geimpft
daher haben wir unsere geliebte Tochter
auch impfen lassen
wir hatten vor der Impfung ein wirklich
kerngesundes lebensfrohes Kind das mit
beiden Beinen im Leben stand
ich zitiere Tim aus der vierten Klasse
ich habe Asthma und muss daher keine
Maske tragen meine Lehrerin setzte mich
in die Ecke ans kalte offene Fenster
damit ich niemanden anstecke
ich fühle mich ausgegrenzt und allein
die anderen Kinder beneiden mich weil
sie lieber allein anstelle mit Maske
sitzen
geben Sie den Menschen ihre Freiheit und
ihre Selbstbestimmung endlich zurück
als nächster Redner hat das Wort der
Kollege Erwin Rödel cdu/csu-fraktion
und erst Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren in weiten
Teilen Europas haben die Regierungen
sich darauf verständigt und Corona zu
den Akten gelegt es handelt sich dort
weitestgehend um den Umgang mit Grippe
oder anderen Erkältungskrankheiten nur
Deutschland will jeder einen Sonderweg
gehen
ohne evidenzgrundlage und ohne
validedaten sollten aber keine Maßnahmen
beschlossen werden
bei auch bei uns hat sich durch
Grundimmunisierung durch neue Impfstoffe
und neue Medikamente die Lage
grundlegend verändert selbst die Welle
im Sommer wurde gebrochen ohne dass das
Gesundheitssystem überfordert war
negative
psychosoziale Auswirkungen auf Kinder
etwa durch Schulschließungen oder Masken
müssen vermieden werden Kinder und
Jugendliche müssen endlich wieder
Normalität erfahren
wir steuern mit Inflation und
Energiekrise ohne hin auf sehr große
Herausforderungen zu auch deshalb
sollten wir die Menschen und die
Wirtschaft nicht noch zusätzlich
verunsichern und belasten ja wir wollen
die vulnerablen Menschen im Kliniken und
Pflegeeinrichtungen schützen aber unsere
Gesellschaft muss den Weg zurück in
Normalität finden wir müssen lernen mit
Corona zu leben ein Leben ohne Gängelung
muss wieder Alltag werden die Menschen
müssen in die Eigenverantwortung
entlassen werden wozu selbstverständlich
auch gehört dass diejenigen zu Hause
bleiben die krank sind
und schließlich gibt es jenseits von
Corona in der Gesundheitspolitik auch
noch andere große Probleme wie wir das
in der Haushaltsdebatte eben gehört
haben die GKV ist
auf seriöse Finanzierung angewiesen die
Eigenanteile in der Pflege steigen die
Digitalisierung lernt die Kliniken sind
in Not es fehlen Ärzte und Pflegekräfte
was soll zur Spezialisierung im
Krankenhaus geschehen was wird aus
diagirreform und Notfallversorgung und
wird zur Überwindung der Sektorengrenzen
und für die vernetzte ambulante
Versorgung etwas getan zu alledem gibt
es vom Minister keine klaren Aussagen
der beschwört stattdessen bei Tag und
bei Nacht auf Twitter neue Krisen
Zustände durch Corona hervor weshalb der
Justizminister ich zitiere in öffentlich
ermahnt die Bürger nicht mit
Horror-Szenarien verrückt zu machen ich
fordere den Bundeskanzler auf seine
Richtlinienkompetenz auszuschöpfen und
den Gesundheitsminister auf den
richtigen Weg auf den Pfad der Tugend
zur Reform des Gesundheitssystems zu
bewegen vielen Dank
ja sagt hier Erwin rüttel für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die Unionsfraktion
übrigens legt hier zur Debatte es wird
ja gleich über die
corona-nobelle hier abgestimmt über das
veränderte Infektionsschutzgesetz aber
auch über diverse Anträge beispielsweise
aus der CDU aber auch aus der
afd-fraktion da spricht jetzt Jürgen
braun herr Präsident liebe Kollegen der
Arzt Dr Paul Brandenburg über die
Stürmung seiner Wohnung am Tag des
Grundgesetzes 23 mai
da standen plötzlich Leute auf mir mit
dicker polizeiaufschrift Helmen und
automatischen Gewehren sie haben mich in
meinem Flur nackt stehend angetroffen
morgens zwischen fünf und sechs
irgendwann rumste es an der Tür mehrfach
ich bin reflexhaft aus dem Schlaf
erwacht und dachte das war es jetzt da
kommen irgendwelche irren um mich zu
killen dann flogen die Türen auf und
fuhr mir standen mehrere Männer in
panzermontour und ich gucke in mehrere
laufmündungen von automatischen Gewehren
und dann bekam ich ein Schild über den
Kopf und einen Stiefel in den Nacken
Zitat Ende
meine Damen und Herren
geben Sie den Menschen ihre Freiheit und
ihre Selbstbestimmung zurück
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Diana
Stöcker
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich blicke mit Sorge
auf die Situation der Reha-Kliniken denn
ich sehe nicht dass die Ampelkoalition
die Verantwortung im Regierungshandeln
übernimmt der Gesetzentwurf enthält zwar
eine Verlängerung des
mindererlös-ausgleichs und
hygienezuschläge für Reha und
vorsorgekliniken aber nur für den Fall
dass die Bundesregierung eine
epidemische Lage erneut ausruft wir
fordern in unserem Änderungsantrag das
Ausgleichszahlungen und Zuschläge bis
zum 30 April 23 verlängert werden ohne
die Voraussetzung einer epidemischen
Lage wir wollen Vorsorge und
Einrichtungen schützen und weitere
Insolvenzen verhindern die Belegung der
Rehakliniken ist in der Pandemie stark
zurückgegangen auch aktuell gibt es
wegen Corona viele kurzfristige Absagen
und vorzeitige abreisen von Patientinnen
und Patienten ohne dass die Kliniken
darauf Einfluss nehmen können ohne einen
finanziellen Schutzschirm droht vielen
Kliniken wirtschaftliche Instabilität
und Insolvenz und damit ein Abbau von
rehabplätzen den wir uns nicht erlauben
können denn der reha-bedarf nimmt Corona
bedingt eher zu und hinzu kommt die zu
Beginn des Jahres vereinbarten Erhöhung
des vergütungssatzes von
durchschnittlich 2,29% reichbarkeit
nicht aus die stark gestiegenen Kosten
des wareneinkaufs und der Energie zu
kompensieren die Rehakliniken sind wie
alle Einrichtungen des Gesundheitswesens
stark von steigenden Preisen betroffen
da sie beispielsweise Heizungen in
Zimmern und Therapieeinrichtungen eben
nicht runter drehen können die Kliniken
haben auch weiterhin Mehraufwand durch
Testungen und Masken der durch den
hygienezuschlag finanziert werden muss
darüber hinaus ist der Tagessatz der
Rehakliniken erhält sowieso sehr knapp
ausgestaltet und deckt nicht nur
gesundheitliche Leistungen Unterkunft
und Verpflegung sondern auch Gebäude
Unterhalt und Sanierung ab es ist also
aus allen drei Gründen für die Träger
der Einrichtungen keinerlei Puffer da um
Kostensteigerung und Verluste auffangen
zu können deshalb liebe ampelregierungen
müssen Sie jetzt handeln sie müssen ja
eine
gesundheitsökonomische Perspektive
einnehmen jeder Euro der in die
Rehabilitation und Vorsorge investiert
wird bringt später einen
volkswirtschaftlichen Gewinn von fünf
Euro
und meine Damen und Herren das Geld für
Corona bedingte mehr Ausgaben wäre ja da
wenn es nicht von der Ampelkoalition für
den Klimaschutz vor umgebidmet worden
wäre bei einem meiner vielen Gespräche
in den letzten Monaten mit Reha-Kliniken
vor Ort wurde mir dieser Staffelstab
übergeben er trägt die Losung Reha
braucht Dich und ich habe das
Versprechen gegeben ihn an
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach zu
übergeben damit Sie Herr Minister sich
ebenfalls für die Reha einsetzen und
sich diesen Auftrag zu eigen machen und
ich würde mich daher sehr freuen Herr
Minister wenn sie sich nach der Debatte
eine Minute Zeit nehmen können damit ich
Ihnen diesen Staffelstab übergeben kann
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
IANA Stöcker von der cdu/csu-fraktion
war das
das werden die beiden dann noch mal
sozusagen bilateral besprechen müssen
jetzt hören wir für die AFD Martin
Reichert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren 12 Jahre habe
ich als Offizier der Panzertruppe diesem
Land gedient in den letzten Wochen habe
ich zahlreiche Gespräche mit Kameraden
der Bundeswehr geführt viele haben die
Impfpflicht nur aus tiefer Sorge vor
Repressalien und aus Sorge um die
Existenzen ihrer Familien und Kinder
zugelassen
wie diese Repression aussieht dazu dass
Zitat eines lang gedienten Kameraden ich
habe einen Eid auf die Fahne geschworen
dass sich dieses Land das Recht und die
Freiheit verteidigen werde wenn meine
Vorgesetzten mir mit unehrenhafter
Entlassung und strafarest wegen einer
Impfung drohen dann läuft aus meiner
Sicht hier etwas verkehrt in diesem Land
und ich muss getreu dem Eid mit ganzem
Herzen nicht diesem entgegenstellen ich
habe keine Angst mehr ich sehe und höre
täglich von Kameraden denen mit Rauswurf
und Gefängnis gedroht wird weil sie die
Impfung nicht wollen meine Damen und
Herren diese Menschen wollen Deutschland
dienen aber es wird ihnen verwehrt geben
Sie auch den Soldaten ihre Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung zurück vielen Dank
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen letzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte ist die
Kollegin Dorothee B und ich darf darum
bitten doch noch ausreichend aufmerksam
zu sein
und die Gespräche auch die Zeit nach
drei Minuten zu verlegen Frau kollegia
sie haben das Wort
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich gebe zu
dass ich in dieser Debatte von der
ampelregierung eines vermisst habe
nämlich auch mal den Dank Herr Kollege
Lauterbach den Dank an die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion weil wir sie
nämlich mit unserem
Änderungsanträgen vor Chaos und vor
allem auch vor Betreuungsnotstand vor
diesem Herbst und Winter bewahrt haben
wenn wir nicht Druck gemacht hätten wenn
wir nicht Änderungsanträge eingebracht
hätten hätten die Menschen in
Deutschland demnächst eine Regelung die
wirklich chaotische Folgen nach sich
gezogen hätte sie hatten nur damit sie
es mal sich klar machen müssen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren auch der
Tribüne Herr Lauterbach hat eine
attestpflicht geplant für Kinder und
Jugendliche bei Corona Verdacht was
bedeutet hätte dass Kinder erst wieder
in die Schule und in den Kindergarten
gekonnt hätten wenn sie beim Kinderarzt
oder beim Hausarzt gewesen wären wenn
das so gekommen wäre wäre nicht nur die
Kinderarztpraxen in Deutschland massiv
überfordert gewesen nein sie hätten auch
das Kindeswohl derer gefährdet die im
familiären Alltag ihre Kinder außer Haus
betreuen lassen und das sind eben die
meisten in unserem Land wir hätten die
Betreuung von Kindern von Jugendlichen
in Einrichtungen der Tagespflege in
Horten in der stationären in obhutnahme
nicht mehr gewährleisten können und wenn
auch schon für die Beschäftigten mit
Erkältungssymptomen ein Betretungsverbot
Vorlesen werde und auch das waren die
Pläne der Ampel bis die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion massiv
eingeschritten hat an dieser Stelle
und was mich wundert ist dass sie diese
Vorgabe auf den Weg geschickt haben 30
Monate nach der Pandemie beginnen und zu
Beginn einer Jahreszeit wo eine
Schnupfennase für die meisten eben
leider auch dazugehört ich will es nicht
verharmlosen ich kann nur hoffen mal
Lauterbach dass eine solche Verschärfung
der Rechtslage wie wir sie noch nie
hatten nur ein Versehen ihres Hauses war
an dieser Stelle aber gut wir sind ja da
wir helfen ja gerne sie haben es
eingesehen haben es gerade noch über
Nacht beseitigt wie sie selbst gesagt
haben und vielleicht ein kurzer Exkurs
damit man mal sieht dass das überall so
passiert beim Elterngeld im März war es
ja ganz genauso wir hatten einen Antrag
der cdu/csu-fraktion zur Verlängerung
der coronabedingten elterngeldregelungen
sonst wäre es auch glatt vergessen
worden von dieser Bundesregierung und
deswegen wie gesagt ein kleiner Dank und
vielleicht auch Herr Kollege Buschmann
ein bisschen weniger Hybris wenn sie bei
so einem Thema sprechen das würde ich
mir ehrlicherweise persönlich auch
wünschen
ein bisschen weniger Buschmann ein
bisschen mehr Lukas Köhler der nämlich
in seiner Rede dankenswerterweise auch
gesagt hat dass es manchmal schwer ist
mit den Abwägungen ja um zu sagen es
geht auch anders in der FDP-Fraktion
aber zum Schluss zurück zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz vor allem als
familienpolitikerin mein dringender
Appell führen sie zielgerichtete
Maßnahmen ein denken Sie an die
Verhältnismäßigkeit und haben Sie ein
besonderes Augenmerk auf unsere
Kleinsten herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Bär